vous n'avez donc aucun dont je peux vous
faire disparaître un bout de chocolat
par exemple attention c'est pas
n'importe quel chocolat non j'ai vu que
c'était du crunch et c'était ma passion
adolescente c'est vrai et adolescentes
n'est plus d'actualité si quand même
vous êtes tombé sur un peu calmée sur le
choco
histoire de garder les tablettes bien
merci beaucoup et rêve je peux faire
disparaître ça dans mon coude par
exemple s'y attendait mais vous allez
servir votre chemise n'ont rien fait le
test quadrant que je prends le chocolat
démonstration je vais le mettre dans mon
cou donc je crois que je crois que je
crois que plus forte que je peux pardon
et au bout d'un moment il va disparaître
dont beaucoup donc la
voie là mais non
attendez mais dont vous avez des talents
d'illusionniste tout à fait c'est
formidable
il va faire la bouche je vois qu'il n'ya
pas de chocolat dans les mange pas par
ailleurs les mouches ah non attendez
vous me promettez de me dire avant la
fin de l'émission
vous me donnez pratique normalement à un
chocolat un magicien de bonnes jamais
c'est tout mais peut-être que là
exceptionnellement jeunes aujourd'hui un
peu plus ça on a aussi envie de vous
entendre en musique vite fait alors bien
sûr on a entendu ce n'est parce que
vraiment je veux juste finir mon tour de
magie non c'est regarder
mais non je reviendrai là extraordinaire
à faire
alors non non mais c'est pas possible il
faut m'expliquer les coulisses enfin je
veux dire pierre niney vous pouvez pas
blessé comme ça je vais pour écouter je
voulais c'était bien ce que j'espérais
faire c'est mon seul bon tour de magie
le reste c'est de là c'est de la très
mauvaise magie bravo franchement le
respect